what's going on guys national master
james canty the third here with
chess.com and today we have
game of the day with the white pieces we
have daniel duvall
and with the black pieces we have sergey
karyakin this is the russian super
finals and if karyakin
is able to win this game he takes so
first
of the russian super finals guys he's
the champ now of course duvall is
not going to let that happen he's going
to play his best and say you're going to
have to get through
me says duboff and here we are e4 e5
knight f3 and knight to c6 bishop c4 and
bishop c5
very easy game could be an evans gambit
it could be a joko piano
something like that italian game type
stuff but after bishop c5 there's c3
from duval then knight f6 i'm going
smooth so far
stuff that they've seen before nothing
spectacular
d4 is the usual move here intending
after he takes d4 we're going to see c
takes d4 you know kind of an easy game
sometimes you can play d3 here but what
happens is he takes d4
usual move and here guys what would you
actually play there are there are a few
alternatives
e5 castling be a move and c takes d4
right
these are the usual moves here but this
is what daniel
duboff played here he played something
completely different and the highest
rated player
to play this move right here guys can
you find the move that was played right
here
here we go guys this is the move b4
can you believe it before i've never
actually seen this myself
so this is definitely some home cooking
some prep that he's done to throw
uh sergey karyakin off here i mean this
was amazing to play b4 now let's watch
the follow-ups here
now after b4 there is bishop to b6 and
then e5 is played now instead of earlier
which is usually played here the best
defense is offense and just because i'm
attacked doesn't mean i have to move my
piece
so after e5 actually d5 is the most
thematic way to play
sergey did not do d5 here and let's
actually take a look at what happens if
d5 happens
f takes e takes f6 is the best way to
play d takes c4 then queen e2 and bishop
e6
and then after b5 making a threat on the
knight knight moves out of the way
f takes g7 rook g8 we take on d4
queen d7 and this is supposed to be what
the position would look like if they
went down that road
with black being slightly better at
actually preparing to castle queenside
but that's actually not what happened at
all it was actually knight to e4 by
sergey karyakin here now after 94
there's a bunch of ways to play guys you
have castle
c takes d4 do we play b5 like what are
we playing here what
what's the move like what do we actually
do here well
let uh let's let daniel to tell you guys
what he did here at the neil bishop to
d5 actually bishop d5 this is the most
aggressive way to play here
it's going to get pretty fun now let's
see what happens here he must capture
the second pawn here
yeah he has to go into this line because
there's really not nothing else to do
here
now after bishop to d5 knight takes c3
from karaoke
knight takes c3 d takes c3 and here we
go guys when you're on the attack
when you gambit something when you're
down material or you sacrifice something
for rapid development
gambits and things like that you need to
keep the attack up so what would you do
to keep the attack up in this move guys
would you castle
would you play like b5 would you play a4
what would you actually play
in this moment here we go guys here's
the move bishop g5 and this is also a
novelty here now it seems like
bishop g5 just an easy move to make i
mean i would play this too because like
we're attacking a queen it's a good move
but he keeps attacking if black if if
uh duboff waits for black to castle here
then queen e8 could be a move so you
want to get bishop g5 in
easily now black must allow this pin to
happen and then 97 this seems very
cramped for right here not the most fun
position
and here we go after 97 there's castles
then there's h6 because he says look
this pin has to go i am tired of this
pin
so the bishop backs up and says not
today and if you want to get rid of this
pin you're going to have to play g5
and we're going to get very live after
g5 and now it's going to be messed up
over here
especially if you're trying to castle on
this side of the board
so at the bishop h4 we have uh castles
very natural move but now uh white
loves engine the the attack here well
the engines love white's attack after
these next few moves after castles
there's rook to e8 guys
just putting some pressure on the file
maybe even some rook lifts maybe e6
could be in the future you never know
it's always good to put a rook on e8
here
but the development for black is not
it's not there it's not existing
a little bit for white too on this side
but we have the bishop swiping the boy
here
and this knight can come into play
eventually maybe through e5 and maybe we
can have some type of queen play let's
see what happens
after rookie eight there is queen to e8
he says you know what i am tired
of this pin and denial plays bishop to
b3 backing it all the way
up maybe bishop to c2 this could happen
too as well
white is definitely in the driver's seat
here guys now watch this
a5 happens and says look we need to make
something happen let's make some trades
let's do something
i need to get my pieces out now white to
move guys make sure you're on your
attacking brain today
hopefully you did your tactics in puzzle
rush on chess.com
now check this out what would you play
as white right here i'm going to give
you a few seconds to figure this one out
what would you play as white right now
here we go guys
a5 after a5 white plays this move right
here
bishop to f6 can you believe that move
right there
bishop f6 is on the board against sergey
karaoke imagine if you are
sergey karyakin right now how do you
feel pressure wise that
i have to win this game to be champ and
i'm now
getting bishop f6 played on me on the
board bishop f6 is a scary move
it's very very scary move here guys and
of course the idea here is after pawn
takes
pawn takes and this is pin and not only
is the king side busted open now
but you have problems and also i'm
getting my piece back
with some interest here so bishop f6
great attacking idea
now after bishop f6 there's a4 on the
board here which was not the best move
they said
um that uh knight f5 actually was it was
an entry something to do here but he
plays a4 honestly because
this is a scary position to be in after
a4 there's bishop to c4 now myself i
would have probably played bishop to c2
and play queen d3 and go in this fashion
but bishop c4 keeps the pin here is what
he wanted to do
bishop c4 then you see knight to g6 and
queen to d3 guys
we're attacking this knight this bishop
is pinning the pawn
your pieces don't exist says duboff
queen to d3 actually and after queen d3
there's d5
i have to do something here and if this
is the best move to make
you might be in some trouble here now
after d5 here we go he takes d6
your queen is hanging oh and your knight
is hanging
oh and you need something else to do
this bishop is hanging as well
watch this guys bishop to e6 is on the
board are you ready for today i hope you
came ready
to watch this video today now i want you
to stop the video right now
and tell me what you would play if you
were do ball in this position
hope you guys are ready here it is here
it is guys this is the move
of the day move of the year guys watch
this combination
here is it if you said queen takes g6
bam oh my goodness there it is in sergey
karaoke and you can probably see
him sweating immediately after this move
maybe flew back in his chair like in the
matrix or something
queen takes g6 happened on the board and
it was a loud
loud clap clatter after clapping the
piece there
it was amazing queen takes g6 is on the
board
and he just stood up and looked at
karaoke probably did in his head
he didn't really do that but i'm sure he
probably wanted to
queen takes g6s on the board sacrificing
the queen guys
and after f takes g6 rook takes e6 to
follow right after here we have all of
this
i in him i mean this is very scary right
now now we got our material back we have
discoveries against the king
well now he has two pieces for the queen
says duboff and we have an attack let's
see what happens
queen f7 he just kind of gets out of the
way here there's discoveries everywhere
so he just kind of blocks the discovery
here and says okay cool yeah you have a
little bit of material
we're not going to give you everything
here's what white does guys watch the
follow-up here
when you sacrifice and you do things
like this you want to wait and you want
to actually look and see what's your
follow-up and you need to know
beforehand before you actually get to
this position
and be wrong so you want to have your
follow-up ahead of time and this is what
he did
what he does here guys bishop takes c3
there is no
need to hurry black can't move the queen
and the king off the a2 g8 diagonal it's
just very hard to do this so
bishop takes c3 he just gets out of the
way here no need to no need to hurry
and then king h80 says look i have to
get off of this as quickly as possible
but then here we go rookie four
now we defend the queen here and if you
look at the compensation here guys
compensation is very very important
one of the hardest things to explain in
chess is compensation
uh yeah i'm losing my queen i've
sacrificed it for a little bit of
material
but i mean we have our minor pieces we
have two bishops in the night
and we have two rooks and a attack
against the black king here
this should be enough compensation here
guys especially as strong as
daniel is playing sergey karyakin it
could be wild here and of course uh
daniel is known for these type of
positions and attacking an aggressive
play
so let's see what happens rook to e4
queen f5 attacking the rook here
you got to keep the attacks up as white
does the same thing you keep attacking
i'm going to keep attacking two as well
says daniel rookie seven hitting g7 guys
this is very scary the bishops in the
rook
work together brilliantly now after rook
to e7 here it is
rook g8 because he kind of has to i mean
you have to defend g7 there's all kind
of attacks
mating threats mating ideas so he says
okay cool you're going to give me the
rook i'm going to take it
now we have two rooks and two pieces and
maybe even a past pawn here versus these
these pieces here
which doesn't look that good guys it
doesn't look that good d takes c7 now i
have almost a queen here
and i have some pieces all i have to do
is trade probably one of the rooks or a
bishop
and we're definitely in the driver's
seat here
after d take c7 he plays queen to c2
here
just keeping some threats on the board
because this is not looking that good
for segay kariakin
he understands that so now bishop to e5
we defend
the c7 pawn with aspirations of queening
later on
now after uh king bishop e5 bishop takes
f2
he just takes the pawn because it's with
check you need to do something and then
the king just steps over
king 2h1 and bishop back to b6 so now
after bishop b6 we have a uh h3 on the
board
king h7 and rookie one guys activating
the last piece
now the rooks are doubled on the file
here this is usually what you want to do
when you have rooks against the queen
here
and then we have some attacks maybe
we're going for rook to e2 removing the
bishop from somewhere
moving it somewhere maybe even bishop f6
and also playing rook to e7 so
there's many moves to go here but let's
see what happens a3 was played what he's
trying to do now
is take on a2 and try to have his own
pass pawn of his own
because this is not looking that good
this rook is only a defensive piece on
g7
the bishop's still doing the same thing
defensive wise trying to keep an eye on
this
and the queen is i mean all the pieces
that black has here kerry hawkins is
only on defense
at this point what a queen sack
sacrificed by duboff
king 2h2 and then we have g5 on the boy
here just trying to make some holes for
the king and do something here
maybe queen back to g6 but as we're
we're running out of moves
we are running out of moves on the other
hand white's actually getting closer to
the king
knight to d4 followed by knight to f5 or
e6 putting more pressure
on the g7 pawn knight uh queen to f
queen to c4 then we have knight of five
threatening g7
queen takes b4 hitting this rook this
rook is
completely defended here what he plays
is rook to c1 hey
we're about to clean okay this
compensation is beautiful
if you watch how all the pieces play
together it's hard to play against all
of these pieces when you don't have
enough material
even having a queen is not enough
sometimes and that's exactly the case
here in this game rook to c1 king to g6
he's out of the way
and here it is guys duval says look it's
time to cash in
this this advantage okay it's time to
show everybody
this queen sack did work and after king
take queen king to g6
rook takes g7 check so now forcing a
rook takes here i mean of course if king
takes f5
which actually did happen but if rick
takes g7 we just queen anyway
so karaoke says okay you know what i
have to take the knight and then rook
takes g8 not only are we we are about to
queen now
now we have two rooks versus a queen and
he only has a queen and a bishop that's
nothing
bishop takes c7 and bishop takes c7 now
after
the dust settles here there's two rooks
in the bishop versus the queen this is
more than enough um for the win actually
for white let's
find a few more moves here queen to b2
attacking the rook
rook to c5 check his king is getting
very very short on spaces
he goes king to e4 and then rook to d8
and then karaoke looked up he looked
around
he took a sip of water he put it back
down he looked at duval
looked down at the position and then
black resigned
right here black resigned right here
because there was really nothing else to
do a sample line would be something like
queen takes a2
and then after rookie five check king to
f4 rook to d4 is checkmate so there's
really kind of no way out of these
things and there's
there's other variations that can happen
here but he realized where he was i
don't have enough my kings looking crazy
in the middle of the street
i have nothing around my king i'm
probably going to be mated with the two
rooks in a bishop or if not losing some
decisive material
meaning the queen here at the end guys
so really really nasty game here let's
actually go back and
with the key critical moment and by the
way anyone that does play the yoko piano
even myself because i love playing the
scotch gambit i'm going to try this out
with this new b4
and see how far we can get here because
do both loves giving us something new
here and after b4 e5 94 bishop d5
nice little sacrifice here bishop g5 i
mean nastiness here
castles bishop h4 and let's fast forward
guys the best move was right here this
was the absolute best move was
here we go here it is queen takes g6
didn't even care about anything here i
mean you you would probably take here
you would look at this move you would
look at this move but queen takes g6 is
just phenomenal guys
queen takes g6 rook takes e6 and now
it's a party
it's a party guys it's a party look at
this this was awesome
this was absolutely awesome dude put on
a show here and
stopped karaoke from winning the russian
super final championship guys
now this was game of the day i'm
national master james cancer iii here
with chess.com and i'll see you guys on
the next video